>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, DC.
>> Megan Metcalf: Good afternoon,
thank you everyone
for joining us today.
For those of you who don't know me
I'm Meg Metcalf, Women's Gender --
thank you, an LGBT Studies
librarian for the main reading room.
So today's lecture is jointly
hosted by the Humanities
and Social Sciences Division and our
friends in the Hispanic Division.
And we're very excited to
welcome Dr. Eugenia Tarzibachi
to speak with us today.
Dr. Tarzibachi holds a degree in
psychology from the University
of Buenos Aires and a postgraduate
specialization in education
from the University Of San Andreas.
She was awarded her PhD with
honors in 2014 from the faculty
of social sciences at the University
of Buenos Aires and the results
of her dissertation research are
the topic of her lecture today.
In addition to her many academic
achievements Dr. Tarzibachi has also
worked in governmental and
nongovernmental organizations
where she has worked to
foster gender equity,
particularly in the field of sexual
and reproductive health
and education.
This year she was awarded
a scholarship
to conduct her postdoctoral research
at the University of Buenos Aires
and her current research focuses
on meanings about menstruation
and menstrual management
technologies for women
of different ages and social
status in Buenos Aires.
Additionally, Dr. Tarzibachi is
working on writing a book based
on her dissertation, as well as a
documentary film on menstrual bodies
and new ways to talk about
menstruation with girls and boys.
Also just a heads up even though the
flyer said 2 to 3, we might also go
over a little bit until 3:30 today.
So on a more personal note,
it is beyond gratifying
to see a scholar conduct research
here at the Library of Congress
and then come back to share
their incredible work with us.
So without further ado, please join
me in giving the warmest of welcomes
to Dr. Eugenia Tarzibachi as she
presented Feminine Protection,
Menstrual Bodies, Gender, and the
Transnational Fem Care Industry
in the United State and Argentina.
[ Applause ]
>> Eugenia Tarzibachi: Thank
you Meg and first of all,
thank you all for being here,
especially on this rainy
day here in Washington, DC.
Let me spend just a couple of
minutes on the acknowledgments
because there are always many
people behind the accomplishment we
can achieve.
So I especially want to thank
Megan Metcalf, Catalina Gomez
and Mary Champagne because on behalf
of the Division of Social Sciences
and Humanities in collaboration with
the Hispanic Division of the Library
of Congress they made
possible this presentation.
So it's a great honor for me to
be here with you sharing some
of the results of my doctorate
of research, which was nurtured
by my work here this library
that I deeply, deeply love.
This institution was
so generous to me
that this presentation here
is a gesture of my gratitude
for hosting me in many
short-time stays over the years.
Here I found some contrary
studies of menstruation while
in Argentina there was none.
My doctorate of research opened
a new area of study in the field
of feminist academic
research in Argentina.
So I also want to thank
all the researchers
on menstrual cycle whose
previous work was crucial
and helped me arrive
to these results.
I won't be able to give credit
to all of them given the format
of this presentation, but
here on the screen are some
of the most important for me.
I also want to thank the
Interdisciplinary Institute
of Gender Status of the
University of Buenos Aires
for hosting my doctorate
of research and also
to my mentors, Monica [inaudible].
I finally want to publicly thank
my sister, Elenora [phonetic],
who is here and her
husband, Indy [phonetic],
who hosted me in their
house with great love
and support all the
trips I made to work
on my intellectual inquiries
here at the Library of Congress.
So let's get into what
gather us today.
The presentation is titled as
Meg said, Feminine Protection,
Menstrual Bodies, Gender and the
Transnational Fem Care Industry
in the United States and Argentina.
This presentation highlights
some of the key findings
of my doctoral dissertation
that was titled,
a genealogy of menstrual bodies
through feminine protection
in the technologies in the US and
Argentina between 1920 and 1980.
My doctoral thesis, in this doctoral
thesis I use the term genealogy
inspired by the work of
Michel Foucault trying
to understand discontinuities
in the discourses
about women's bodies
as menstruators.
So to perform this reconstruction
I conducted a thorough analysis
from the 1920's to the 1980's as
it relates to the rhetoric exposed
in advertisements mostly
graphic of pads and tampons
in the social context where these
images circulated in both countries.
I review more than 400 ads.
I also looked for the
most significant patterns,
the educational materials
produced by the main companies
of this industry, and
the experiences of women
about the menstrual body,
as well as the meaning
that these modern technologies
represented for those who live
through the transition from
the rag, cloths and cotton
or reusable homemade products
to manufacture disposable ones.
And as it relates to the
latter analyses and in order
to understand what happened
in Argentina I interviewed 30
Argentine women who were teenagers
and young adults during the 70's
when the tampon was
launched in that country.
To retrieve equivalent at that time
in the United States I relied
on background research.
I also conducted an interview with
managers of multinational brands
of feminine protection products
in Argentina and in the US.
And I also interview
Argentine gynecologists
who were practicing
medicine in the 70's.
The transnational dimension of
this study is aligned with the idea
of understanding the relations
between these two countries instead
of doing a comparison,
although sometimes we know
that it's unescapable.
I supposed this study
in transnational feminist cultural
studies, a tradition started
by Caplan and [inaudible] in 1994.
You may wonder why did I concentrate
in the relation between the US
and Argentina and I cannot
say that the emergence
of femcare industry was initiated
in the US, but the main companies
and brands that introduced
the innovation of disposable
and manufactured pads and tampons
in Argentina were Americans.
That is why the counterpoint
with the US was crucial.
These companies disseminated
the disposable pads and tampons
in steps first the pads, then
the tampons from the upper
and middle social sectors
to medium and low
and from the center
to the [inaudible].
This means from the central
to the [inaudible] countries
and from the central
to the [inaudible] areas
inside the national borders.
Such has been the consolidation
of this industry internationally
that as [inaudible] said, its
annual earnings at the beginning
of the 21st century were around
$17 billion in global sales
and this is still expanding mainly
by the growth of emerging economies.
Currently in the United States
the four major companies competing
in this market are Proctor
and Gamble, Kimberly-Clark,
Johnson & Johnson and
Playtex products.
All by Playtex are the ones
that developed extensive
multinational corporations
and in Argentina, Johnson & Johnson
ranked first in the local market
of pads and tampons since the
early 30's with introduction
of modest past brand to the present.
So as I mentioned, in my research
I focus in the period of time
between 1920 to 1980, I wanted to
include the whole period of time
in which the pads and tampons
where launched in both countries.
In this presentation I will
be extending that genealogy
of menstrual bodies to
the present to introduce
and close this lecture today.
The reason for that is
that those discourses
on women's menstrual bodies are
unstable and in dispute nowadays.
Also because what is currently going
on only can be deeply understood
considering what happened during the
20th century.
So I want to start this presentation
describing three current public
situations that took
place in Western societies
and went viral in social media.
Each of them in different
ways expose
that in the 21st century
what is popularly known
as the menstrual taboo
is not only still alive,
but also is regulating
women's bodies
and [inaudible] in the shadows.
So the first situation was in
August 2016, the Olympic Games.
Fu Yuanhui, a Chinese competitive
swimmer got the fourth place
in the competition.
She apologized to her team
because she could not do
her best performance given
that she had her period the
night before the competition
and she had menstrual cramps.
Let's hear from her about
the emotion of shame
that so intimately constitutes the
corporeal experience of menstruators
in our societies and particularly,
in traditionally masculine
fields such as sports.
[ Foreign Language Being Spoken ]
Okay, so this disclosure
seemed to be a revelation
as if it was a novelty that
[inaudible] as the majority of women
in reproductive age do
menstruate every month and continue
with their regular activities.
So let's move on to the second
analyzer also related to sport.
However, this one could
be considered as part
of the current menstrual activism.
This is important because
what you will see
in this situation is social also
an emotional self-evaluation,
but the opposite emotion
to shame, pride.
So the second situation was in
April 2015 in the London's marathon.
Kiran Gandhi had a choice
to skip her first marathon
because of her period or run
the marathon and she decided
to run the marathon and
practice free bleeding
for sisters who don't have tampons.
This is the image of
the end of the marathon
and she was criticized
as being disgusting.
The third situation in March 2015
Instagram removed twice this picture
from the photographer Ruby Kaur
for considering it offensive.
This picture was part of an
essay on a visual rhetoric course
at the university she attends.
I will read the answer
[inaudible] to Instagram
by the end of this presentation.
So what I would like you could
remember of these three anecdotes is
that the public reaction
to what these women disclosed
are proportional to the success
of the process that accord
during the 20th century and in
which the femcare industry
had a significant protagonism.
The idea that I would like you could
gently keep in mind until the end
of the presentation is that
with the efficient concealment
of the menstrual body what was
better concealed under the discourse
of women's liberation
was the menstrual stigma.
In other words, we can say that
the menstrual closet a concept
that I borrow from Iris Marion
Young was better locked and hidden.
So next in this presentation I will
try to show you that the disposable
and manufactured pads and tampons
which were massively launched
in the United States and
Argentina at the beginning
of the 20th century were far more
than innocent modern technologies
of menstrual management.
Let's remember that before
the commercialization
and massive consumption
of industrial pads
and tampons each woman
had to handle what to do
with its own menstrual blood every
month and women weren't allowed
to do many activities during
menstruation like taking cold baths
or doing energetic movements.
In the US and in Argentina what
women usually used were cloths,
rags and cotton.
Sometimes they'd [inaudible] to
hold their homemade pads in place.
The massive dissemination
and consumption
of these products helped
women gain a sense
of self-control over
their own bodies.
They also helped them manage
menstruation in a standardized
and practical way with
increasing comfort
and at a less emotional cost.
Furthermore, they increased the
productivity of women's bodies
at different levels by letting
them perform a socially acceptable
feminine body before others
and remain active every
day of the month.
So the question is
how they did all that.
And the answer is by normalizing
the menstrual body gradually
under the idea of a feminine
body for which menstruation was
under control the processing
played two major tactics.
The first one and most fundamental
was effectively conceding not
suppressing all the evident
traces of menstruation,
even its consideration of abject
by letting women be more
productive every day of the month.
This meant a decreased anxiety
related to the subservience
over the evidence of the
existence of a menstrual body.
Manufacturing of disposable pads
and tampons helped women avoid
in a more efficient way the sting,
the smell, the visual traces
of a homemade pad and
also they were disposable.
So women did not have to worry about
finding a place to hide the product
for store it or where to dry
them without being seen by men.
And finally the improvements in
terms of comfort made women get rid
of the permanent self-awareness
about the menstrual condition
without suppressing menstruation.
That's why I conceptualize by using
the Freudian concept of denial
as technologies of effective denial
of the menstrual body traces.
The second major tactic
was the following.
The industrial patent tampons
were disseminated alongside a new
legitimized way of thinking
and talking about menstruation,
which was supported by the
biomedical modern knowledge.
This new way of doing, thinking
and talking about menstruation
that this industry disseminated
transnationally displaced gradually
the traditional knowledge
of women about menstruation.
The work of [inaudible] and
Elizabeth Kisling were crucial
to understand what
happened in the US.
The dissemination of industrial
patent tampons transnationally
helped women disidentify with
that old-fashioned menstrual body,
but by being commanded
by traditional practices
around menstruation could not
hide properly all the traces
of menstruation and remained passive
or inhibited during
the menstrual period.
And finally, the powerful
connotation of the disposability
of the blood and the
products was helpful
for that disidentification process.
It had resonances with the
metaphor of an abject body,
an old-fashioned menstrual body
that could also be discarded.
However, the [inaudible] menstrual
body was kept alive under wraps.
So in conclusion, industrial patent
tampons were and are far more
than technologies of
menstrual management.
I will show you that
they are a prism
to understand how its transnational
dissemination and consumption
in the US and in Argentina produce
a new disciplinary practice towards
women's bodies that
normalize menstruation.
In a long-term basis this new
disciplinary practice not only
conceal menstruation in a more
efficient way and provided a new way
of thinking, talking and
managing menstruation.
In a broader perspective they also
reproduced traditional narratives
about gender and helped to
conceal the menstrual taboo
or a stigma while maximizing women's
productivity every day of the month.
I would love to share many really
fascinating details and complexities
of this process, but as
I don't have enough time
for that this afternoon I will focus
on the portrayals of women's bodies
as menstruators in the
transnational discourses
that the femcare industry
used to disseminate the pads
and the tampons as
feminine protectors.
I will focus on the two main
ways to do this dissemination
which were [inaudible],
the advertising
and the educational materials
in both countries between
1920 and 1980.
So let's first make some
sense about the title
of this dissertation
or this presentation.
This image is just one of
the first advertisements
of Kimberly-Clark's brand of
feminine pads called Kotex.
And it is very simple,
but it is revealing.
I selected it because its main
[inaudible] is explicit and crucial
to understand the culture and
construction about gender related
to the menstrual condition of
women's bodies that the market
and that the feminine
protection rhetoric has sustained
for almost a century through
the technologies in question.
Women lose because they menstruate.
That is to say that women
lose blood and the also lose
in the social field because of
their natural deficient bodies not
because the cultural corporeal
idea of Western societies
that is a non-menstrual
idea like male bodies are.
I want to bring here
Elizabeth Cross [phonetic]
about the continuous transcriptions
that the Western culture made
about women's [inaudible]
as a seepage.
According to Cross, women's
bodies were socially constructed
as some uncontrolled
chaotic fluidity,
a content with no solid container.
Since the beginning
of the 20th century
that rhetoric reinforced a
particular metaphor about women
as victims of their
natural weak, vulnerable
and problematic bodies
even that they menstruate.
Menstruation was portrayed as an
enemy opposed to the social equity
of women that is why the patent
tampons were feminine protectors.
So I won't talk much about the
euphemisms that the industry used
to refer to menstruation
or the products
at the beginning of
the 20th century.
I won't even talk about the
[inaudible] to refer to menstruation
that is already a fact that
many research studies have
already concluded.
What I would like to do now
is to unfold the metaphors
of menstrual bodies
reproducing the history of pads
and tampons advertisings in the US
and Argentina using the menstrual
taboo to conceal not only the blood,
but the menstrual stigma itself.
So let's take a look at the story
of the feminine protection
rhetoric in the advertisements.
I organized what you will see
in a chronological timeline,
so we will be traveling from the
20's to the end of the 70's back
and forth between a
central country like the US
to a peripheral one like Argentina.
From the analysis it can be observed
that the masculine protective power
of pads and tampons over women
worked very close to the sanitation
of the menstrual body
considered dirty
until the 50's capitalizing
the hygienist discourse.
And from the 60's on the feminine
protection work in solidarity
with the liberation of women
from an oppressive menstrual body
capitalizing the culture and power
of the women's liberation movement.
So in the first period,
what I call the first period
of feminine protection I will
be showing you the anachronistic
feminine protection rhetoric divided
into these two periods
in both countries.
The first one goes from the 20's
to the 50's and the protection
of this chaotic vulnerable
and problematic menstrual body
was linked with its sanitation
because that body was
also considered dirty.
This period coincided with the
release of the first generation
of both products in the US and
just the modern sanitary pads
in Argentina.
In this period we will see images
like this one, a woman in panic
because she was discovered
by others as menstrual.
We can understand the particularity
not only as a commercial strategy
that worked explicitly around
an ashamed and dirty body
that could not integrate
into the society.
This portrayal can be understood as
a reflection of an ongoing process
of disidentification from that
old menstrual body that used
to fail in the concealment.
That process was not complete
yet, disposable tampons
and pads were still
massively consumed.
This is another example of
an Argentine advertisement.
It says scared, no
more uncertainties.
Modess the safe sanitary napkin.
So the second period of feminine
protection that coincided
with the second generation of both
technologies started in the 60's.
By a second-generation of these
products, I mean the innovation
of the adhesive and later different
sizes and wings in the pads.
And the second generation of
tampons in the US meant tampons
that could expand longitudinally
not radially and also the tampons
with no applicator with [inaudible]
that were unnecessary, etcetera.
In Argentina the innovation
of the tampon
as a menstrual management technology
was systematically presented
in society through advertisements
from the late 60's and 70's.
Approximately 40 years later
than here in the US and the one
that is most consumed
in Argentina is the OB,
the [inaudible] tampon
with no applicator.
So let's also remember that
the tampon as a technology
of vaginal penetration
awakened many social
and individual anxieties
related with women's sexualities
and is a very interesting
analyzer of the social regulation
of women's [inaudible] in
each of these countries.
During this period, the
protection of the chaotic
and vulnerable menstrual body
was linked with the liberation
of women considered as
objects socially oppressed
by their own natural
menstrual bodies.
In these periods we can't
register anymore the representation
of an ashamed woman that could be
discovered by others as menstrual.
This advertising strategy coincided
with a process of disidentification
of that old menstrual body that
was started to be consolidated.
So this is just a general
classification of two periods
to clarify different metaphors
of menstrual bodies according
to really big tendencies
that I could find.
Protection, hygiene and freedom were
three signifiers that work together
and acquire different accents
due to the historical context.
They were a stable
[inaudible] of meanings
that the femcare industry used
to portray women's
bodies as menstruaters.
So with these new modern products
the [inaudible] oppressed during
menstruation that prevail
at the beginning
of the 20th century
started to be fractured.
So let's start with
the first period.
You will see highlighted in yellow
the word protection or references
to safety and in blue the
word hygiene or sanitation.
And given the time
constraints I will go
over each relevant ad fairly
fast, but there are many,
many interesting about each of them.
I will spend just a
couple of minutes
on these foundational
images published in 1921
in the Ladies Home Journal.
This is the first ad of Kotex
pads which used the discourse
of patriotism to launch the
brand and the technology
into the American market
after the First World War.
In this ad what was used is
an analogy between the pad
as a protector of a vulnerable woman
that menstruate and the soldiers
who were fighting to
protect the American nation.
A feminized entity as it was
under the threat of a war.
And also menstruation is along
with the idea of the enemy.
The word protection you will see
that it doesn't have a strong
presence in this first ad,
but [inaudible] connotation
of this image is
around the feminine protection given
by a masculine and American figure.
The ad says to save a man's
life science discovered Kotex.
And this ad led us to a keynote.
You may know that the feminine pads
designed to manage menstruation were
as many other modern
technologies a consequence of war.
This is one of the products created
for the war that after the end
of the war had a civilian use.
The [inaudible] higher
absorbent material and cheaper
than cotton was produced by
Kimberly-Clark in 1915 due
to the rising prices of the cotton
after the American Civil War.
So Kimberly-Clark used to sell it
to hospitals as surgical dressings.
In 1917, when the US entered
into the First World War the
company started to sell this product
to the American army
and the Red Cross.
And after signing the amnesties in
1918, the Army canceled the contract
with Kimberly-Clark and
[inaudible] and many fabric
that produce it were remaining
as a potential business loss.
So Kimberly-Clark decided
to capitalize both actives
and transformed the
cellucotton into a feminine pad.
As [inaudible] said in their book on
Kimberly-Clark the only one factor
that could persuade a businessman to
think about the menstrual condition
of women at the beginning
of the past century was
a potential profit loss.
It is also said that the idea of
this derivation of the cellucotton
into the feminine pad came from
the American fund of wounded women
to Kimberly-Clark saying that the
nurses of the American army used
to improvise the use of cellucotton
surgical dressings as feminine pads.
So they call it Kotex referring
to cotton-like texture.
Now the text will have
some sense to all of us.
I will just read some parts.
Our boys were falling wounded
in the battlefield of France,
army doctors were calling
for an unlimited supply
of antiseptic surgical dressing that
will be more absorbent than cotton.
The government said can you give us
such a surgical dressing,
we could and did.
[Inaudible] men working
in a feverish pace built a great
plant here near the forest district
of the north and a wonderful
surgical dressing was produced.
Hundreds of thousands
of pounds were shipped
to our war hospitals
to save men's lives.
Many a sorely wounded
soldier has reason
to thank American scientific
inventive genius
to this great practical discovery,
a permanent peacetime utility.
Now that the war is over we
are devoting this great factory
to peacetime usefulness we have
called this wonderful product Kotex,
Kotex Texture and before long Kotex
will be available in restrooms,
dry goods, departments and
drugstores all over the country.
So the cost is almost nothing,
our plan was to be able
to fill a war need, enormous
production was demanded,
we will keep that production
up and keep down the cost.
Kotex are cheap enough
to throw away.
So this is a foundational beginning
of the transactional feminine
care rhetoric to advertise
in this case pads without
mentioning not only menstruation,
but neither the product
they were advertising.
So let's move on in
this first journey.
Next, let's take a look at
this ad published in 1927
by Johnson & Johnson
in the Syracuse Herald
to presenting society
it's feminine pad modest,
a derivation of the word modesty.
At that time Johnson &
Johnson started to compete
with Kimberly-Clark
for market share.
It says a personal word to women
from Johnson & Johnson we ask you
what a modern hygienic convenience
should be like and you told us.
Then we experimented, our 41 years
in making Red Cross cotton gauze
and surgical supplies helped us.
So Modess [inaudible] comfortable,
it gives absolute protection,
it is easily disposable.
Modess is the truly modern
hygienic convenience designed
for the active modern woman.
Modess is all you need
to say ready wrapped
at most drugstores
designed by women for women.
So there is a story also behind
this ad because Johnson & Johnson
to release this brand they hired a
PhD in psychology Gilbert [phonetic]
that a study how was
the best [inaudible]
for the five senses of women.
So after that study they
released this brand.
And there is a beautiful
paper made by [inaudible]
about this [inaudible] report.
So the aim of this new product
was more comfort for woman,
but also better concealment
of the product.
The allusion to the active modern
women that needed a new way
to manage menstruation
will remain a staple.
In 1928 Kimberly-Clark launched in
the Saturday Evening Post many ads
like this one in a new campaign
that portrayed upper
class women using Kotex
as a sign of social distinction.
Kimberly-Clark made a rhetoric shift
from the previous ad
Kotex protection
and hygiene was no more a
matter of national convenience,
it was a sign of social distinction.
So this one says, this
ends the worries
of full-time hygienic methods
by providing protection
but is absolute.
And this other one
says, the safe solution
of women's greatest
hygienic problem which 8
in 10 better class
women have adopted.
So you will see from now on
until the 60's approximately
that the menstruation was portrayed
as a problem, a feminine problem.
So let's move to this image.
I picked this advertisement
published in 1933
in the New York Times
by Kimberly-Clark
because of this insistence of the
protection and the equalizer effect
between men and women that this
new technology was pretending
to bring about for women.
Let's remember that the right for
women to vote as men did was passed
in 1921 and that is another
milestone of the American history
that was capitalized by the
first ads of pads and tampons.
It says now great advance
in sanitary protection
equalizer Kotex gives [inaudible]
greater protection.
And now we arrive to another
memorable advertisement
of this story.
It is the one that introduced
the tampon Tampax in 1936.
The quality of the image
is not good at all.
I can tell you that there
are many women represented
in action riding horses, playing
tennis, using swimsuits thanks
to the protection that
could be worn internally.
This technological innovation
was portrayed as revolutionary
for women corporeal
experience as menstruators.
And it was because it gave a step
forward not only in the habilitation
of doing many activities
that require water
or any energetic movements
because the leaking
threat was better solved.
Furthermore, the menstrual
management technology itself could
not be seen by anyone
else than a woman.
So tampons were launched as a way
to remake woman's tortured existence
with this new way to
fixing their deficient body.
But they released Tampax with a
nicer translation than what I did.
They said, welcome to this
new day for womanhood.
This summer you can experience
the comfort and unassurance
of [inaudible] you have
never known before,
sanitary protection worn internally.
Or this other advertisement
that says women's world remade.
So around the same year that
the tampons were launched
in the American market.
In Argentina Johnson & Johnson was
started at least in advertising
to release the feminine pads.
These ads published in a feminine
magazine that still exists
that is called Para Ti, For You,
are part of the first ads
of Modess brand I found.
As you can tell in the image on the
left they used the representation
of the woman with a very
short masculine haircut called
[foreign language].
The equalizer effect of
men and women by the use
of this menstrual management
technology was connoted here too.
It says something like every woman
needs Modess, the sanitary napkin
that will give you the most perfect
and absolute protection during
the days of indisposition.
This is a traditional
way of referring
to menstruation in Argentina.
Get a box of Modess in
any pharmacy or a store
and you will prove why Modess
gives a complete protection,
a product of Johnson & Johnson
Modess this modern sanitary pad.
The image in the middle of the
slide also showed upper class women
under a title that says
the modern solution
of a known feminine problem.
Notice the same insistence on
the consideration of menstruation
as a hygienic problem of female
bodies that could turn into a crisis
because of what they referred as
an accident during those days.
And the third ad used
the image of a nurse,
the only one feminine representation
of medicine at that time to declare
in the title, a new chapter in
feminine hygiene with this safe
and comfortable system, Modess
the safe sanitary napkin.
[Inaudible] with the modern
way to manage menstruation
of the modern woman in contrast with
the old-fashioned methods and women
that were prisoners
of the problematic menstrual
body was strongly emphasized
in the Argentine advertisement
of the novelty of this product.
Let's take a look at
these in the first ad
of national pad brands in Argentina.
The ad on the left, at the left of
the slide used a title that resounds
with some other ads
we have already read.
How the modern woman
solves her hygienic problem.
The ad of the right side of
the slide showed a dialogue
between Luisa, an old-fashioned
woman, and the modern woman.
The modern woman who is
seated in the chair says,
how outdated you are
Luisa that is not a reason
for not going to the party.
What you have to do is try
[inaudible] sanitary napkin
that is a solution for our problem.
This national brand called
[inaudible] combines the word
sanitation or health and napkin.
The slogan was [inaudible]
the modern sanitary napkin.
And this one this ad, I love this
ad because this is an isolated ad
of a tampon on the 30's in Argentina
or at least it's the only one
that I could find in my
review published in 1939.
It disappeared very quickly
from the domain of advertising
and I could not find any
other ad of this technology
until the 60's in Argentina.
This advertising reveals
something that was not possible
yet for Argentine women in the
late 30's probably given the more
conservative context
over women's bodies
and the smaller local
market compared to the US.
It was a national brand of
a tampon named Absorbol,
the name is a homophone in Spanish
of the English word absorb all.
As you can tell again,
the Anglo-Saxon origin was an
important source of legitimacy
of these products in Argentina.
So let's move on to the
ads introduced in the 40s's
and the 50's they present
many, many interesting stories.
In those years the use of
feminine pads became products
of massive consumption
here in the US while
in Argentina the companies
were still trying
to target the middle class woman.
And in both countries the
increasing participation of women
in the workforce as blue-collar
workers was represented into the ads
to portray these technologies
as a way
to help women be active
every workday.
They continued using the
representation of menstrual women
as a desirable object
for the [inaudible]
by concealing properly their
properly their menstrual condition,
but also they were able to
be economically productive,
not only as consumers
but as active workers.
There are differences found in
the way they portray women working
in one country and the other due
to particularities of
its social context.
In the US where women had to occupy
men's work position when they were
in the battlefield during the
Second World War women workers were
portrayed with traditionally
masculine [inaudible] like overalls
and slacks or poses open legs.
In Argentina, they
continued being represented
with the traditional feminine
clothing like blouses,
skirts and dresses and with all
the traditionally feminine gestures
like crossed legs while seated.
Let's take a look at the images.
As you can see in the
ad published in 1942
in Women's Home Companion the figure
of the traditional feminine woman
who is the fan of her husband's
furlough while his sword is pointing
her sexual organs is balanced with
a masculinized [inaudible] worker.
Both had to keep going
during menstruation.
The Tampax ad in the middle
says those modern girls
as never before need
Tampax showing a giant woman
as a result of a low angle shot.
She's standing with her legs open
saying slacks, slacks, slacks.
The [inaudible] of this word
refers not only to the trousers,
but also to a loose part, something
like a loose part of our bodies
that was [inaudible] by the tampon
to become solid and hermetic.
Let's remember here
the ad women lose
and the consideration
of women as a seepage.
Finally the image on the right
represented again the blue-collar
workers and Tampax as
an ally of capitalists
to reduce female absenteeism
during menstruation.
And in the meanwhile ads like
this one were published in 1945,
the modern way to think
about those days.
Physical educators now stress
normalcy for this time of the month.
As you can see in this ad, this
was part of the very strong process
that had the intention of deepening
the portrayal of menstruation
as a completely normal
biological process.
This is a very -- there is a
very interesting story mentioned
by some authors like [inaudible]
who refer to how in the US,
particularly in the
US the normalization
of menstruation was intense during
the World Wars time period and how
after the war the [inaudible]
of women
because of menstruation
was highlighted.
The psychological distress
related to hormones
like the menstrual tension
created by Grover Frank in 1936
or the PMS created
by Katharina Dalton
in 1952 are an example of that.
This can be understood as
a way of displacing women
out of the workforce to let the man
occupy again their places at work
since they were coming
back from the war.
Aligned with this phenomenon
you can see the return
of the traditional
feminine stereotype of women
in the campaign Modess because the
Johnson & Johnson released from 1948
until the brand Stayfree
was launched in the 70's.
So let's move to what happened
in these decades in Argentina.
There were not as many
representations
of women working in Argentina.
There are some examples of them.
The lowest class status
of the workers portrayed
[inaudible] not only in the types
of jobs they were performing,
but also in the main [inaudible]
of the ad of the left
slide of the slide.
The buttons of your
suit are more expensive.
The other two ads showed
[inaudible] women at the store.
There were also secretaries
at the office
in other ads I didn't select
it for this presentation.
But the topic of the absenteeism
that pads could prevent
remain unmentioned.
The pads for workers
were portrayed as an ally
to perform the idea feminine
beauty also during menstruation.
So during the 50's there were less
workers in the ads and more sense
of women's menstrual
bodies being active
and impeccable housewives
like this one.
These said -- oh sorry, it says
will you be a good housewife
and it's like a test.
If you answered yes to the
second question, then you will be
in this case a good housewife.
It's like a campaign, there are like
five, it's a set of five images.
For example in the box, sorry
this is a little bit more.
In the box number two it
says, do you buy things
because they are cheap without
worrying about its quality
or number two, do you prefer to buy
many little things products instead
of depriving yourself of
modest safe protection.
Or in box number four, do
you allow your discomfort
to deny your loved ones of your
good mood and collaboration.
Or number two, do you know how
to take advantage of the comfort
that Modess provide
and leave your life
under its safe protection,
just say Modess.
Other ads are like this one,
traditional [inaudible] women
dancing in love with men
without concerns with the
safe protection of Modess.
Modess is simply not cotton its
absorbency power is far superior.
Modess especially designed for
being invisible under the light
of stress, just say Modess.
So let's move to the second
period of feminine protection.
Now we will highlight
the words protection
in yellow and freedom in green.
This rhetoric is very much like
to what we could appreciate
from the last decades of the 20th
century until 2000, colorful ads.
Women under the water during
menstruation, the presentation
of new brands referring to freedom.
And a second generation of
pads and tampons in the US
and also the presentation
of the tampon
in Argentina are the main
characteristics of this period.
I agree with Shelley Parker in the
[inaudible] that we can register
in the advertisements of pads
and tampons while the women's
liberation movement was taking place
in both countries.
This shift goes from the
rhetoric of the sanitation
of the menstrual bodies they told
you considered dirty to the rhetoric
of women's liberation
of menstruation
as an internal enemy for women.
Just keep in mind that in
Argentina during the 60's
and the 70's we had many
dictatorship governments.
Let's take a look at the
ads of the second period.
Nothing holds you back, this
is an ad of Tampax published
in 1968 in Family Circle.
It says whenever you go, whatever
you do, you are confident,
comfortable, carefree
with the cool, clean,
fresh protection of Tampax tampons.
This is modern sanitary protection,
the kind that belongs to the young,
the [inaudible], the alive.
It even makes you feel
more a part of the party.
You get total freedom with Tampax.
Or these two between 1974 and 1976,
these new brands of pads introduced
by Kimberly-Clark and Johnson
& Johnson were released.
They highlighted the word
freedom in their own names.
New freedom displays Kotex
and Stayfree displays Modess.
They had of course, this new
generation had the adhesive backing
as the one that we know in our days.
As you can tell, teenagers
were a clear target for tampons
in the 70's why swimsuits had a very
strong presence in advertisements.
This is like the new aesthetics
of the 60's and the 70's.
And in Argentina for example,
this ad published in 1976
in Revista Clarin, it's a
very traditional magazine.
This ad is a national
brand of a tampon
in Argentina that was called Suavix.
The ad says Suavix for
women's liberation.
The text talks about menstruation
as one of the last taboos
and the visual connotation
of menstruation related
to an empty nest, can
you see it right there?
It's interesting because it refers
to the hegemonic way to think
about menstruation as an
indicator or a trace of a body
that is [inaudible] that spoiled
its reproductive potential.
It's an empty nest.
If we have time we will see one
of the ways this interpretation
of menstruation was disseminated.
There are some tampon
ads of national brands
in feminine magazines during the
70's, but after the OB tampon
of Johnson & Johnson was
released they disappeared
from the domain of advertising.
Well this is the second ad that
present the OB tampon in Argentina.
You can tell that there are women
in bikinis running out from the sea.
And the last stop in
this first journey
through the feminine protection
rhetoric is the comparison
of the simultaneous first ads to
present the OB tampons in the US
and Argentina and I have to thank
here to David Linton for putting me
in contact with Robert Wainer,
who managed the public relations
of OB brand for Johnson & Johnson
in the 70's here in the US.
And kindly shared with me the
first OB American campaign
of OB tampons for TV.
This is a fixed image
just I captured that image
that is the end of the advertising.
I would like to show
you the different ways
in which this technology
was presented
in the ads making a [inaudible]
use of women's liberation discourse
that was contemporary and
also the political use
of the dictatorship
discourse in Argentina
that among other things
censored feminism.
During this period
that goes from 1976
to 1983 Argentina suffered
its cruelest dictatorship
of its whole history.
The state terrorism used the
doctrine of national security
against an internment enemy and the
discourse of the total protection
to disappear and kill
30,000 men and women due
to their ideological
conventions about social justice.
So in the US the OB tampon was
presented as a feminist technology
because of three main things.
The first one is that
it had to be inserted
into the vagina with our own hands.
Let's remember that the discourse
of the women's health movement here
in the US used the symbol of the
speculum as a way to call for women
to explore their genitalia in 70's.
Second of all because they portray
an androgynous woman riding a bike,
running in a park, and using
very, very loose clothing.
And the ad [inaudible] of
medicine as a figure of legitimacy
that they refer to
a gynecologist woman
as being the creator of OB tampons.
This denoted that women could
be professionals as men and also
that come essence of
women's experience
of menstrual bodies could
understand better women's needs.
On the contrary, in Argentina
the OB tampon was presented
as a feminine technology,
not a feminist one.
Using the discourse
of women's liberation,
but in a very different way.
It was the first ad of a
menstrual management technology
that showed the inside
of woman's genitalia.
I don't know if you can tell
right there in the left side.
Let me see if I can
point it with this, yeah.
Right here this is the inside of
the genitalia, woman's genitalia.
But they showed that image in a
very pragmatic way just to show
where the tampon had to be
inserted exposing that a [inaudible]
about women's anatomy was needed.
The clitoris of course, was omitted.
This ad still used the discourse of
the figure of the masculine medicine
that they refer to the approval of
this tampon by male gynecologists
to legitimize the tampons.
And the ads portrayed a sexy
woman moving with no restrictions,
but in the position of
objects of male desire.
The ad says, tampon OB of Johnson &
Johnson asks the feminine protection
you use would allow you
to pose for this picture.
In both cases that's appropriated
feminism in a politicized way
to promote technology that could
hide more efficiently all the traces
of menstruation.
And something else was found in
the ads of OB tampons in Argentina
where the society was invented
as a told you in a great
and social anxiety that is reflected
in these women's body's portrayal.
The discourse of the feminine
total protection to make reference
to a bleeding that had to be hidden
had a strong resonance with the one
that the dictators used
to legitimize the aberrations they
perpetrate during what they called
the dirty war to free Argentina.
So what I tried to show you
until now at a glance is
that the feminine protection
rhetoric
that the so-called femcare
industry used was a constant
and it was transnational until our
days with some twists according
to specific social context
where they were presented.
These negative connotations
about menstruation
by giving a technological
fix to that object
and the [inaudible] menstrual
body in order to allow women
to maximize their productivity
every day of the month.
But at the same time it wouldn't be
fair with the feminine care industry
if we don't say that the
companies also worked
around the positive connotation
about menstruation given its
relation with the female fertility.
They highlighted this aspect
in the educational materials
where they continued
reproducing traditional narratives
about gender while doing its
[inaudible] on this new modern way
to manage and behave, think
and feel about menstruation.
Let's remember here that
the [inaudible] departments
of the companies started their
work at the 40's here in the US
and around the 60's in Argentina.
There are many educational
pamphlets and films here in the US
from the 40's, but I just found
one pamphlet in Argentina produced
by Johnson & Johnson
at the end of the 60's.
So let me show you one
educational material,
a memorable one is the
story of menstruation
that Kimberly-Clark asked
Disney to produce in order
to disseminate its products
between the youngest.
It was released in 1946.
[ Music ]
>> Why is nature always
called Mother Nature?
Perhaps it's because like any
mother she quietly manages so much
of our living without our
ever realizing there's a
woman [inaudible].
You wake up with no
more conscious planning
than we used in [inaudible].
Mother Nature controls many of
our routine bodily processes
through automatic control
centers called glands.
The story of menstruation
really begins
with one particular gland
it's located here at the base
of the brain and it's
called the pituitary gland.
In our childhood years this
pituitary gland concentrates
on producing growth hormones.
Busy little messengers which
circulate through the bloodstream.
They order the various bones
and tissues to get growing.
And as a girl grows up and
[inaudible] to dolls to books
that means her body is
obeying the orders issued
by the pituitary gland.
Of course, these orders
vary among different girls,
some girls grow short, some
tall, some heavy and some slight.
But there comes a time somewhere
between the ages of 11 and 17 though
about 13 is average when
the pituitary must turn part
of its attention to maturing
the body which it has grown.
So it starts sending out a new
type of hormone, a maturing hormone
and that is when menstruation
begins.
When these maturing
hormones start coming
down through the bloodstream
to the ovaries.
The ovaries themselves are
glands about the size of almonds.
And locked within each
ovary are thousands of eggs.
Although these eggs are too small
to be seen by the human eye any one
of them has the possibility of
someday becoming a human being.
Near the ovaries are
the fallopian tubes,
short canals which lead
to the uterus or womb.
This hollow pear=shaped organ
opens into the vagina which is part
of the birth canal and
is the external opening
for this whole group of organs.
So as you see, there is a
continuous passage from each ovary
through the fallopian
tubes, uterus and vagina
to the outside of the body.
These organs function
in a continuous cycle.
The pituitary gland
starts the process
when it sends its maturing hormones
down through the bloodstream
to the ovaries.
Now one of the ovaries passes on
an order of its own the uterus.
It tells the cells which make up
the lining of the uterus to multiply
and fill themselves with
watery fluids and blood.
This begins the buildup, a thickened
lining of somewhat velvety material.
At the same time an ovary has
been maturing an ovum or egg
which is magnified here
so that we can see it.
About once a month one of these
tiny eggs passes out of the ovary
and finds its way into
a fallopian tube
where it moves along
toward the uterus.
If the egg is impregnated, which
happens when a woman is going
to have a child, the egg
will stay within the uterus.
Then the thickened lining
will provide nourishment
for the budding human being through
the early days of its development.
However, most eggs pass
through the fallopian tubes
without being fertilized.
When this happens there's no use
for that potential nourishment
in the buildup lining of the uterus.
And so in a few days it
passes from the body.
This is the flow which
we call menstruation.
>> Eugenia Tarzibachi:
And we move forward now
because this is what
I wanted to just
to take a look, you can take a look.
And now the [inaudible]
towards femininity.
>> Of course a girl may be irregular
during the first year or so,
but after that when her system
has settled down into a routine,
her period should always be about
the same number of days apart
and last about the
same length of time.
Try not to throw yourself off
schedule by getting overtired,
emotionally upset or catching cold.
And if your timing goes seriously
wrong or you are bothered
with severe cramps or headaches, you
should have a talk with your doctor.
Of course, you'll want to
keep a personal calendar.
Mark the first day of each period
and check to see that there are
about the same number
of days between periods.
It's not only a useful
record of past performance,
but it comes in handy when
you have to plan ahead.
This calendar appears
in an interesting booklet
called very personally yours.
This booklet has been prepared
to enlarge upon what you
learned from this brief film.
Among other things the
booklet explores that old taboo
against bathing during your period.
Not only can you bathe,
you should bathe.
Because during menstruation
your perspiration glands are
working overtime.
Just be careful to avoid either
very hot water or very cold water.
In fact, it's not a good idea
to anytime to shock your system
with extremes anymore
to let yourself get
chilled or to catch cold.
And as for the old taboo against
exercise, that's nonsense.
Exercise is good for
you during menstruation.
Just use common sense.
When you come to think of it,
most of your daily routine
is on the mild side.
It's going to extremes that's
wrong and to be avoided.
>> Eugenia Tarzibachi:
Look at this, look at this.
>> To most girls the menstrual
period should bring no
severe discomfort.
Some girls have a little less
pep, a feeling of pressure
on the lower part of the body,
perhaps an occasional twinge
or a touch of nerves, but
don't let it get you down.
After all no matter how you feel,
you have to live with people.
You have to live with yourself too.
And once you stop feeling sorry
for yourself and take those days
in your stride, you'll
find it easier
to keep smiling and even tempered.
You can do practically
everything you normally do.
[ Music ]
Provided you take common
sense care of yourself.
Exercises to relieve cramps are
illustrated in the booklet try them
with the guidance of
a qualified person.
You may find they help.
And do something about that slouch.
Sloppy posture is just as bad
inside as it looks outside.
So stand up straight and
let the organs function
from the position that
nature intended.
One way to help them function
normally is to avoid constipation.
Your reproductive organs lie
between the rectum and the bladder
and their external opening.
And constipation will disturb the
relationship between these organs.
So you'll find it worth your
while to drink plenty of water,
eat plenty of fruit and to
include cereals and eggs
and leafy vegetables in your diet.
And incidentally, it's
smart to keep looking smart.
That well-groomed feeling will give
you new poise and lift your morale,
especially when it's backed up with
year round fresh air and sunshine
and plenty of rest and sleep.
Because the best possible
insurance against trouble
on those days is healthy
living every day.
And that's the story.
There's nothing strange nor
mysterious about menstruation.
All life is built on cycles and
the menstrual cycle is one normal
and natural part of
nature's eternal plan
for passing on the gift of life.
[ Music ]
>> Eugenia Tarzibachi:
Okay, it might be funny
but this was reproduced
in the majority
of the educational materials
with some [inaudible]
of course, but until the 80's.
So as Iris Marion Young pointed
out before, such an insistence
of the normalcy of
menstruation is an indicator
of its pathological consideration.
But let's go back to the positive
connotation of our menstruation
as the one that is
generalized today,
the educational materials
for the youngest.
That was crucial to complete the
normalization of the menstrual body.
The positive connotation
of menstruation was
portrayed like this.
First of all, menstruation was a
sign of the welcoming to womanhood.
The traditional monism becoming a
young lady or [foreign language]
in Spanish helped to hide what
is a gender identity construction
within the [inaudible] norm
as a natural derivation
from the pretended
abstractive reality of the body.
And in the place when menstruation
was explained in a scientific way
from a medical perspective
reproducing a gender binaries
through the figure of
a natural sexy body
with particularly reproductive
organs and hormones
that allows the biological
reproductive capability
of female organisms.
We can continue unpacking
the re-inscription
of traditional narratives
about gender following the
brilliant work of Emily Martin.
On the one hand menstruation
was explained using the feminine
stereotype of a passive egg that
slowly comes down to the encounter
of the masculine stereotype of an
active sperm that conquers the egg.
Something really interesting
in these materials produced
in both countries between
the 40's and the 80's is
that the sperm was never seen in
the imagery that they provided.
On the other hand menstruation
was noted as a waste and natural
and [inaudible] chance to be
pregnant and be a mother someday
as if motherhood was the
correct destiny of a woman
because of her natural body.
I have to say here that
menstruation can also be explained
within those scientific terms.
For example, as a defense from the
pathogens transported by the sperm.
The biologist Margie
Profet had a very,
very interesting paper
on this topic.
Furthermore, the educational
materials did something else,
they represented an idea menstruator
in introducing many other
disciplinary practices towards the
body apart from concealing
menstruation
with feminine protection products.
The idea menstruator was a desirable
and modern feminine young woman
from the perspective
of the masculine gaze
and the strong presence
of the mirror
in these materials is a strong
connotation of that gaze
that was portrayed as starting
to regulate the feminine
existence since the menarche.
So let's take just a quick look
at the presence of the uterus
of course embedded in this narrative
about the reproductive capability
of women's bodies and the mirror
in some of these materials.
This was published in 1952 and
it had new editions in 1959
and 1961, You're a Young Lady Now.
It was a pamphlet produced
by Kimberly-Clark.
There you can tell that the image
of the mirror is a constant.
In Molly Grows Up it was
another film produced
by Johnson & Johnson in 1953.
There you have the teacher that is
explaining almost the same thing
that we saw in the
story of menstruation
about the body's menstruation
related
to the reproductive capability
of women's bodies and then Molly
in front of the mirror when she was
just about to have her menarche.
This is another pamphlet,
It's Wonderful Being a Girl,
published in 1986 produced by
Johnson & Johnson, the same thing.
And this is the only one material
that I told you that I found
in this period in Argentina it
was called Learn to be a Woman,
A Confidential Message
are Female Teenagers.
This was a pamphlet
produced by Johnson & Johnson
and one really interesting thing
is that the imagery of the uterus
and the internal part of
women's genitalia is not seen
in these educational
materials in Argentina.
So it also [inaudible] make
sense with the advertisements
of OB tampons that there was a
[inaudible] that was still remaining
in Argentina for woman,
for women sorry.
And there is a short, but very
powerful paper on this written
by a Dacia Charlesworth
that applied perfectly well
to characterize the idea menstruator
in this educational materials.
In her study of American
pamphlets from 1959
to 1998 she summarized exceptionally
well that the idea menstruator had
to be a mother someday, had to
use the proper scientific names
when discussing the menstrual
cycle, has to discuss menstruation
with another woman and
trusted adults only,
but will not be confident when
discussing menstruation with others.
Although she doesn't feel her
best she will not use menstruation
as an excuse for behaving badly.
She will know that menstruation
should be kept in secret.
She will practice using feminine
protection products before the
need arise.
She will be willing to
engage in bodily [inaudible]
and she will use the various
feminine protection products
mentioned in the pamphlets.
It's interesting because if you
analyze these materials you could
tell that in the US until the end of
the 50's they just recommended pads
for teens and by the end of the
50's they started to suggest the use
of tampons for teenagers too.
On the contrary in Argentina,
by the end of the 60's
the educational material
that I found was still
suggesting just the use
of pads for young women.
And I have to say here that the
companies had a great work in trying
to eliminate social and personal
fears over tampons as something
that could make woman loose
something really valuable
for our society such as virginity
or they could incite masturbation.
And I could add one
more characteristic
of the idea menstruator
[inaudible] standard
of how normal menstruation
should be --
doesn't apply for her
particular case,
the idea menstruator
should go to the doctor.
Finally, the educational materials
of the companies did one more thing,
they prohibited some
activities during menstruation
that today seem to be ridiculous.
Some were very similar as what
traditional knowledge used to advise
for example, not taking
a bath or a cold bath
or doing energetic movements.
And while the decades passed by they
eliminated all those prohibitions
and that seemed to
coincide with the moment
in which the tampon became
suggested for teenagers.
So I tried to show you
how the normalization
of the menstrual body
during the considerable part
of the 20th century helped
to maximize women's body's
productivity while re-inscribing
traditional gender narratives
in many different levels.
And as a result of these new
disciplinary practice towards
women's bodies not
only all the traces
of menstruation were concealed,
but the menstrual stigma
was better concealed too.
So this will present a historical
interest [inaudible] frame
that allows to understand
why this way
of menstruating is
currently in dispute.
I would refer to this point
to close my presentation
because it opens new
questions for further research,
the pursuit to continue
[inaudible] work
about women's menstrual
bodies to the present.
And there are some new
narratives around menstruation
in the femcare industry of
central countries and I have to say
that none of this is
happening in Argentina.
They still maintain menstrual stigma
because they are advertising pads
and tampons to efficiently
conceal menstruation,
but they are deepening the
rhetoric of women's empowerment.
A couple of examples
are the following.
The first one an ad of Always
brand, a Procter & Gamble brand
for the American market
shows a generational change
in the experience of being
a woman towards what we can
call self-confidence.
But menstruation you will
see is never mentioned.
Let's take a look, this
campaign is called Like a Girl.
>> Hi, okay so I'm just going
to give you some actions to do
and [inaudible] the first
thing that comes to mind.
Show me what it looks
like to run like a girl.
[ Music ]
Show me what it looks
like to fight like a girl.
[ Music ]
Now throw like a girl.
>> My name is Dakota
and I'm 10 years old.
>> Show me what it looks
like to run like a girl.
[ Music ]
Throw like a girl.
Fight like a girl.
What does it mean to you
when I say run like a girl?
>> It means run [inaudible].
>> So do you think you
just insulted your sister?
>> No, like yeah [inaudible]
girls, but not my sister.
>> Is like a girl a good thing?
>> Actually I prefer [inaudible],
it's a bad thing or good thing.
It sounds like a bad thing,
it sounds like you're
trying to humiliate someone.
>> So when they're in that
vulnerable time between 10
and 12 how do you think it
affects when somebody uses
like a girl as an insult?
>> I think it definitely drops their
self-confidence and really puts them
down because during that
time they're already trying
to figure themselves out.
And when somebody says you hit like
a girl it's like well what does
that mean because they think
they're a strong person,
it's kind of like telling
them that they're weak
and they're not as good as them.
>> And what advice do you have to
young girls who are told they run
like a girl, hit like a girl, hit
like a girl, swing like a girl?
>> Keep doing it because
it's working.
Somebody else says that running
like a girl or kicking like a girl
or shooting like a girl is something
that you shouldn't be
doing that's their problem
because if you're still scoring
and you're still getting
the ball all the time
and you're still being
first you're doing it right,
it doesn't matter what they say.
I mean yes, I kick like a girl
and I swing like a girl and I walk
like a girl and I wake
up in the morning
like a girl because I am a girl.
And that's not something
that should be ashamed of it,
so I'm going to do it anyway.
That's what they should do.
>> If I asked you to run like a girl
now would you do it differently?
>> I would run like myself.
[ Inaudible Comment ]
[ Music ]
>> Why can't run like a girl
also [inaudible] win the race?
[ Music ]
>> Eugenia Tarzibachi:
Rewrite the rules.
So the second one is another
body form from UK and it talks
about a blood that should not
hold us back, but it is related
with the pain and the effort of
practicing a sport professionally
and menstruation again
is still a metaphor.
This campaign is called blood.
[ Music ]
Live fearless.
So this is what is new under the
sun the femcare industry rhetoric
to refer to menstruation
in advertisements.
But in addition new technologies
of menstrual management started
to have a strong presence
in the market from the end
of the 20th century and the
beginning of the 21st century.
On the one hand new reusable
products such as the menstrual cup
or pads made of fabric that
you can use, wash and reuse,
the panties that include sort of
a fabric pad such as [inaudible].
They pretend to break the menstrual
taboo, but they are still trying
to guarantee the efficiency
in avoiding the leaking.
So I use quotes in the word new
because as you probably know,
some of them are not new at all
and especially the menstrual cup.
Here you can see that there are
many patents of menstrual cups
in the 30's here in the US.
These technologies are supported by
discourses related to ecofeminism
and some others that relate
menstruation with positive,
powerful, very essential
connotations of women's organisms.
These technologies are a real
reaction to the menstrual taboo
that the femcare industry
perpetrated under the rhetoric
of liberation not only for
concealing menstruation,
but also because all the unhealthy
issues related with dioxins
or dioxins and other
toxic substances found
in pads and tampons.
The most renowned episode
was related
with the toxic shock syndrome
in the late 70's here in the US,
but there are still many
studies in the US and Argentina
that nowadays finding
toxic substances
in industrial pads and tampons.
And just related with the
unhealthy issues of pads
and tampons there are also new
tampons made of organic cotton
and some new brands, technologies
like tampons with vibrators
to relieve the menstrual cramps.
On the other hand other
significant industry,
the pharmaceutical one started
to commercialize massively
last generation contraceptives
that suppress the menstrual cycle.
They are supported by minor
medical discourses that believe
that menstruation is unuseful and
even harmful for women's health.
[Inaudible] you may know him,
is one of the biggest
exponents of this discourse.
These contraceptive methods
are advertised in the US
as a convenient way to get rid of
the burden of menstruation not only
as a way of avoiding very
important health issues related
with the menstrual cycle.
And from the results of my
research my hypothesis is
that the femcare industry
helped women disidentify
with the menstrual body
during the past century
and help the pharmaceutical industry
go for a more radical solution,
the menstrual suppression.
On the one hand the femcare industry
needs women to bleed as much
as possible and on the other side
the pharmaceutical industry needs
women to feel blood
as an inconvenience.
Finally some words about the field
of menstrual activism very well
understood by Chris [inaudible]
as a part of a third
wave of feminism.
Menstrual activism tends to
support the reusable methods
that portray menstruation
as a positive experience
of women's bodies.
And they work to do many things,
including getting menstruation
out of the closet.
All the social media reactions
related to what I showed you
at the beginning of these
presentations, I mean the practice
of free bleeding, the
social exposure of leaking
or just the disclosure
that women menstruate
in certain territories
traditionally masculine,
such as sports can be read
as signs of a well-nurtured
and still alive menstrual stigma.
In the 21st century we can say
that we made great advancements
in the feminist agenda.
The gender equity is still
incompletely conquered,
the lethal violence against women
is facing them in the more privacy,
genital, productive
and subtle violence
like the symbolic violence
toward women as I described it.
And the most interesting
part of the story is
that that violence is concealed
under the look of a discourse
of women's liberation
or women's empowerment.
So I would like to end
my presentation saying
that feminism is not a
bad word, we need feminism
which is not an anti-man
movement as the media
and some common sense
thinking like to portray it.
Feminism is a way to understand and
expose social inequalities related
with sex gender system in
all its intersectionality
with different forms
of social oppressions.
This is to say that if
feminism is a bad word,
it's an essential bad word.
And we need more feminist research,
but we also need to take it
out of the [inaudible] of the
books and the scientific events.
We also need action
and concrete change.
So as I said, I would like
to finish with the voice
of [inaudible] her
public answer to Instagram
after they censored her
image of menstrual leakage.
And I'm paraphrasing Ruby Kaur
as if Instagram was just a voice
like any other voice of the society
that thinks that symbolic violence
against women is a minor issue.
She said, thank you
Instagram for providing me
with the exact response my
work was created to critique.
You deleted my photo
twice stating that it goes
against community guidelines.
I will not apologize for not
feeding the ego and pride
of misogynist society that will
have my body under an underwear,
but not be okay with a small
leak when your pages are filled
with countless photos and accounts
where women so many who are
under age are objectified, pornified
and treated less than human.
Thank you.
Thank you so very much.
[ Applause ]
Okay.
>> Megan Metcalf: Do you feel
like answering questions?
>> Eugenia Tarzibachi: Of course.
>> Megan Metcalf: Does anybody have
questions they would like to ask?
>> I'm proud to identify
as the professor Kiran Gandhi
[inaudible] in my classroom.
>> Eugenia Tarzibachi: Wow.
>> A symbol and she's supposed
to be here tomorrow night.
>> Eugenia Tarzibachi: Wow.
>> [Inaudible] excuse me on
Tuesday night [inaudible].
One of the things I
notice in your excellent,
outstanding presentation is
how often women are scolded
to make sure they are pleasant,
good-tempered, in a good mood
for others and we assume for men.
My first reading of the
image about, you know,
women save men's lives I didn't know
it was about the use of cellucotton.
I assume that ad was
that women stayed
on the production lines longer
because they had hygiene products
and, therefore, helped win the war.
I feel like almost every image
comes back to managing your symptoms
to make life more pleasant for men.
Do you want to comment on that?
>> Eugenia Tarzibachi:
It's interesting
because maybe it's the male
gaze, it's not just men right
and it's not performing on
ideal femininity for men.
Actually you get like not a
very nice reaction when you talk
with women and you say
something like this.
They'd say I don't dress
for a man for example,
some women don't like to hear that.
I think that the intersection
of the male gaze it's a strong
cultural [inaudible] that I tried
to show something related
with this in this study
that has sexually Foucault
in the base.
I don't know if I answer what --
well it's like a reflection right.
Yeah, I would say something
like this,
it's like the male
gaze surveillance.
>> Yeah.
>> I'm interested to know what
you think about the [inaudible].
>> Eugenia Tarzibachi:
Oh yes, it's interesting.
I think that New York is
already doing that right.
I think that it's great because.
[ Inaudible Comment ]
Well in the 70's there was
written a very nice essay
about what would happen if men
could menstruate from Gloria Steinem
and she said that pads and
tampons would be free probably
between many other things.
Well actually I think that
it's an interesting initiative
because this is one of the things
that we are asked to perform,
we are asked to conceal menstruation
to perform an idea of femininity,
so at least they should get rid
of the tax from the products.
So I think it's a good initiative.
But it's also good to
disseminate, to disseminate --
well what is happening
with the toxic substances
that they are still found
in pads and tampons.
I am not sure of how
dangerous they are
that I read many current
papers on that.
So I don't know if the
industry has enough strength
to hide those results
of these studies.
But I think that it's a good
initiative, but at the same time I'm
like a little bit worried
about these findings.
Probably the menstrual cup
is the best technology,
the more innocuous technology.
Well and some other thing that I
would like to add to that answer is
that for example in Argentina we
have a public national program
of reproductive health.
And we have like had big variety
of contraceptives that are free
for women, women from
low social status.
And they don't have any technology
to manage menstruation and actually
when we have like a natural disaster
in Argentina probably here it
happens the same way I am not sure,
but in Argentina they
don't give women menstrual
management technologies.
I think that it's so well hidden
that they forget about
women's needs.
>> Megan Metcalf: All right,
I guess that wraps this up.
Thank you so much [inaudible].
>> Eugenia Tarzibachi: Thank
you so much, thank you.
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at LOC.gov.